[Music]
homie look what I become
you're actually being serious first of
all I would love to see the conversation
with you and Ludacris for four hours
what was that about oh my God you know
what it was it was um we had built an
app at go TV called hip-hop official and
um are you joking are you being serious
no I'm being very serious and I told him
about it and I connected them to the
producer of it and we used to do
you know reviews of new drops because
you don't call it an album don't call it
a CD maybe three four songs did he tell
you about his Cadillac Grills yeah check
out his he was he was actually very cool
he was excited about he about some of
his songs were going to movies yeah
anyone to do that awesome you get that
soundtrack stuff and you make money on
it yeah well like I say all the time Tom
nobody's more hip-hop than the business
no but actually it was kidding me this
is a guy that comes to the office
listening to hit him up every morning
unique taste for anyways okay folks if
you just joined in welcome to the
podcast this is home team today we got a
lot of topics
um I got uh uh javelins I want to talk
about the amount of missiles Javelin
missiles we've given to U.S and and
we're given to Ukraine and if you see a
couple of the numbers I saw I couldn't
believe it by the way on how many
contractors U.S dealt with just 30 years
ago in 1990 to how many we are today and
where the CEO of Raytheon and and north
and Northrop Grumman these guys are
telling America to say listen all this
Javelin you're sending to Ukraine you
don't even know how long it's going to
take us to rebuild them you're running
out so by the way the supply shortage on
that we'll cover that cars I'm gonna
show you a video same dealership just
eight months ago what it looked like
versus what that dealership looks like
today okay today in February we'll see
that uh clip as well obviously we got to
talk about the article that came out
from Wall Street Journal talking about
lab leak go most likely origin of
covid-19 pandemic energy department now
says and mainstream media says they
don't know what they're talking about
apparently they've lost their minds
Larry Summers uh discusses the interest
rates as well as Yellen times got some
thoughts on that
two actors both great actors Woody
Harrison from his best movie Harrelson
the best movie ever played in which was
obviously white guy come on now and he
called out everybody on SNL it was so
quiet you can tell everybody was awkward
yes talking about the biggest drug lord
in the war in the world then Brian
crainston does the complete opposite
talking about Trump's America make make
America great again slogan is racist a
Democrat Marianne Williamson a close
friend of Adams is going against Biden
I'm sure you got some thoughts on that
the Santa says ex Disney seal complained
of pressure over school bills and he
signs a bill placing Disney's District
under State Control couple articles
Tom's got commentary on home prices will
sink in these cities that were once red
hot as Supply starts to overwhelm demand
and another article that says is now a
good time two sell your house the John
Sanders said a couple things about
recruiting quarterbacks versus defensive
ends which some people laughed about it
some people say well that may be a
little bit crazy and Tom Brady may go
into comedy by the way but before we get
into it let me give a quick shout out to
our sponsor uh Aura this is very
important for you to be listening to
this part guys if you haven't already
taken advantage of these guys and what
they do it is real it is happening uh a
cyber theft today where people are going
after in the cyber crime today where
people are going after credit cards you
saw the other day where how people are
going into phone starting to sell things
you're starting to see people using your
social and all of a sudden you got three
credit cards they're sending it to your
house saying hey I didn't apply for
these credit cards if you're not
protecting yourself for somebody that's
been insurance for 23 years now 22 years
now I'm all about protecting and being
preventative this is one smart simple
way to stay safe online
cybercrime is the head of uh now uh
robberies so if you want to take
advantage of that contact Aura today's a
podcast uh is sponsored one of the
sponsors today is Aura uh uh protect
yourself and your family from America's
fastest growing crime try Aura free for
two weeks and see if any of your or
family's personal information has been
compromised you can actually see how
many of your passwords are used on the
dark web couple of our guys tested if
you've not done it go ahead and do it
start your 14-day trial at aura.com
forward slash pbd once again aura.com
forward slash pbd Rob put that link in
chat in description for people to find
it having said that let's get right into
home prices we'll sing in these cities
that were once red hot as Supply starts
to overwhelm demand so let's take a look
at these cities and then Tom I think you
got a couple thoughts about what's going
on with real estate and he said there's
a couple things that came out this
morning
Goldman Sachs predicts that home prices
will sink 19 in Austin 12 in Seattle 16
in Phoenix 15 in San Francisco by late
2024 compared to late 2022 levels while
the housing market overall remains tight
those four cities have seen big
increases in inventory and supplies
overwhelming demand Goldman sees a 6.1
percent decline in home prices
Nationwide for 2023 as mortgage rates
head back to six and a half percent
which could be attributed to Federal
reserve's aggressive rate hiking cycle
housing affordability is currently at
historic lows and median existing home
prices for all housing types in January
was 359 which is 1.3 percent increase
from the same month in 2022 sales of
existing homes have dropped 12 straight
months and buyers are starting to gain
more purchasing power and potentially
benefit from lower home prices Tom
well what we're getting is what's called
a rollback and a rollback is when maybe
something spikes up and then it rolls
back immediately because the maybe the
spike wasn't uh what it should be all
those cities Austin Seattle Phoenix and
San Francisco had real big spikes
between July of 21 and the end of 22.
and so now that's kind of coming back
down a little bit and those people right
now are panicking because you know
realtor knocks on your door and says
hello sir yeah you know your home was
worth uh 450 a year ago now your home's
worth seven they're looking at that
they're like I should Harvest this
profit and so they're putting them on
the market but they're putting them on
the market at a time where the prices
are shifting and so it was so much on
the market if you can stomach the
interest rates like six and a half right
now those markets are good place to
start uh looking around the buy I know
that doesn't help you with any here in
South Florida we were talking about you
looking for a condo South Florida not
the place to be doing that right now it
has hasn't shifted that much but Pat
what we're seeing is a rollback in the
super Spike and now there's so much on
the market buyers have choices so buyers
with good credit they can get that and
stomach a six percent six and a half
percent mortgage have an opportunity
here and by the way if the rates go down
in a year and you refi at 375 or four
but um that's what we're seeing in these
markets it's not the same in the rest of
the United States so is this a good time
to buy or sell well if you're in a
market where the rollback's coming back
and there's some you know some
opportunities there and I would compare
the price that you're looking at on the
rollback to January February March q1 of
21. compare it if it's coming back there
now you're coming back in reality yeah
and so I would say make sure you make it
it's not just that the price is dropping
from where it was yesterday it's where
the price was dropping from where it was
at the beginning of 21. and uh Tom so
those places you said San Francisco
skull I mean Austin it's you know it's
growing but like Seattle and San
Francisco why are why is all this
inventory coming on people just leaving
because the people are trying to harvest
what I read this morning
um and uh went to nerd wallet they have
a really great writer there who is very
moderated and steady in its analysis and
they were pointing out that these were
the areas that had super spikes and the
the tenor from sellers is hey prices are
starting to go down you know what I want
to harvest the equity that I got in here
I want to harvest the profit and then um
go figure something out well let me let
me read this article and I'm going to go
to you so is now a good time to sell
your home wsg I'm going to put these two
stories together in today's housing
market it's important for sellers to
price their homes appropriately as
buyers are more price sensitive due to
high mortgage rates and overpricing
could lead to fewer offers sellers in
middle and lower priced segments of the
housing market are faring better while
those in a higher priced Market are
experiencing price drops uh according to
Rob Barber's CEO of atom Data Solutions
it is also essential to avoid
overpricing which can backfire as buyers
are often working with smaller budgets
and don't want to spend time negotiating
with the seller interesting overpricing
could backfire on the seller lastly
sellers may want to wait until later in
the selling season to list their homes
as the five days in which sellers
receive the best premium over their
asking price were during the third and
fourth weeks of May interesting so the
best time to sell your house is third or
fourth week of May May 23rd was found to
be the most profitable date with a 18.3
percent premium above market price May
23rd Adam thoughts well I was chuckling
a little bit because both of you guys
before even Benny asked they're like no
Vinnie now is not the time to buy right
now okay as many every episode please so
so it's now the time yeah in South
Florida and so exactly well here's how
I'm processing all this real estate wild
swings it's the same thing that we've
seen with everything we've seen with the
U.S savings right rates and with credit
card debt since since basically covet
started we've seen these wild swings in
how much money people are saving and now
how much debt they have these stimulus
checks the printing of the money
the at the end of the day even with
inflation rates and interest rates covid
lockdowns everything we're still you
know on our path to this return to
normalcy right so that that's I think
what's happening here now specifically
those cities we've all seen what's
happened in the stock market and NASDAQ
over the last 12 months they've been
deflated so you're talking Seattle
you're talking San Francisco you're
talking Austin very Tech heavy cities
meanwhile you have cities that are big
in lifestyle like South Florida Miami
Boca West Palm Fort Lauderdale they're
increasing so ultimately what does this
come down to it's supply and demand
basic rule of Economics so I too would
look into a place in South Florida
relatively soon if possible but I don't
think that's on the horizon right now oh
great yeah I have to tell you like if
there is a market where there will be
desperate sellers that's all I was gonna
ask you no there will be desperate
sellers because people have attended
history has proven based on a lot of
studies done on 113 billion people that
have lived people have a tendency of
making bad decisions really and when
they make bad decisions they become
desperate
by the way by many scientists on both
sides yeah so so meaning when bad
decisions are made things go for sale
which means there's a lot of things
that's going to be on sale whether it's
in a great Market bad Market terrible
Market but some markets are going to get
hit harder than others there's no
question about I'll start asking last
question not to cut you off Tom just you
three please just one that day comes
just because I'm not asking no only if
you promise to stop asking a question
I'll tell everybody that's watching I
will never ask again just when Bliss one
day when it is right walk in and go no
no okay that's it because my mom is I
have to handshake agreement we'll
probably be six months too late because
no one can predict that yeah but what
you just need to know is it's a hit and
miss you know you the other yesterday I
got interviewed by a guy he calls me
says yes and we'd like to interview you
because we saw that you uh sold your
Wayne Gretzky card for record-breaking
number the two PSA TENS for 2.2 million
so I'm like okay this guy's calling from
Canada it's a big paper they're
interviewing I want to go to this year's
Nationals the big card the convention
that they do or I got I know a couple
hundred thousand people go to it so so
how does it feel when you bought this
card for 540 000 and you sold it for 2.2
million I felt it felt great I said but
it didn't feel good six months later
when one of my cards sold for 3.75
billion oh wow wow
but that's going to be a 20 million
dollar card in the next 10 20 years okay
it's gonna that card you you you're not
gonna get your hands on that card you
may never see that card for the rest of
your life ever again it's not a Unique
Card here's the point to time everything
you're you have to be very lucky to time
and there's people that are going to
time it and get lucky with it uh you
want to make the right decision based on
what's going on right now to me in my
opinion there's still a lot of
uncertainties there's uncertainties with
investigations there's uncertainties
with interest rates there's
uncertainties with war there's
uncertainties with debt there's
uncertainties with leaders at the White
House there's uncertainties with
election there's a lot of different
uncertainties this is a good season to
look for some opportunities I think when
unemployment if unemployment to me hits
the five percent
if there's a marker I would use to buy
and make aggressive offers would be if
unemployment gets to five percent that
would be my marker so forget about what
I'm saying forget about what anybody
else is saying if unemployment's hitting
five percent that is a good time for you
to say I think this is a good time for
me to go and make some offers because
there's probably going to be some
desperate sellers that here's just what
happens to life and it's a very ugly
part of life I was a kid my parents went
through a divorce when divorces happen
one of the two is going to say I don't
care what you do sell the house I Want
My Equity out of the house so one has to
sell yeah it's like but wait babe if we
sell today why are you being so dumb and
greedy did you call me dumb I'm gonna
call the lawyers sell the house right
now it's worth 1.2 million if we wait
for six months we can get 1.2 I don't
care sell it today you sell it for 9.50
sure well the buyer made 250. yeah I
don't know if you understand what I'm
saying so they're buying rate 250
divorces are about to go up if
unemployment goes up these things these
live things are going to happen it's
just it's what's gonna happen when
people get fired life is hard finances
are hard meeting your expenses is
difficult and the first thing that takes
the biggest hit is what marriage when
marriage takes a hit people make bad
decisions financially most people are
not ready financially most people are
not ready to get married financially let
alone when they get married and a big
crisis takes place then they make some
desperate decisions which is selling
things that they should probably be
sitting on they sell it for pennies on a
dollar go ahead let me ask you I feel
agree that the hardest thing to do is
time the market you know they say that
the one thing you need to know about
investing is not timing the market it's
time in the market we've all heard this
before
um I've I've learned this in real estate
you know I'm more of a real estate guy
I'm sorry I've learned this in the stock
market more stock market than a real
estate guy but what do you think is
harder to time
I wouldn't it would be probably more
appropriate to say it's harder to time
the stock market because there's less uh
there's more things going on that that
you kind of got to be paying attention
to versus in the real estate market it's
interest rates right uh the job markets
and um obviously dealing with people's
equities in their homes but as far as
timing goes because that's a very good
question you're asking I think it's a
lot easier time real estate than it is
for time stock market if you're 100
right last week was a weird thing the
stock market did you guys see the stock
market every day bam bam bam bam bam
what the hell is going on right Bam Bam
Walmart Target oh it's because of this
oh it's because of interest rate it's
because of that but you know real estate
you know it's not a as faster of a
process I want to go into car sales to
show you something but before I do time
I'm going to give you the last word on
uh real estate before we move to the
next topic uh I I was just gonna say
unemployment rate Seattle's unemployment
rate is almost four percent it been
hovering around 3.2 3.4 but we we heard
about layoffs at who micro soft Amazon
so we've seen a lot of tech layoffs so
you've got the Seattle going on and to
to Pat's point you know the unemployment
rate may not be a national figure you're
looking at it may be a local figure it's
a very good point and it's a very good
point so what you see here Seattle has
flagged they were at 3.4 3.5 the end of
the year and with the things up there
one thing I read is that the next next
announcement is probably going to be
four percent 4.1 in Seattle and what Pat
just said is keep your eyes out when it
hits five percent in your market and if
you're in a steady industry you've got
something else going you have an
opportunity Rob pull up what I just sent
you right there Tom you just made me
Google unemployment rates by state you'd
be amazed who's the highest before you
show it before you show it don't show it
don't show it I don't even want them to
see it what state do you think has the
highest unemployment right now what
state has the lowest
very interesting because this is where I
was going because the national
unemployment rate is what three and a
half percent 34 35 right now okay what
do you think is the highest
I don't think you're gonna get it as
your first just take one guess you're
not gonna guess I'm gonna guess West
Virginia you're saying California Los
Angeles the lovely state of Los Angeles
I'm saying an obscure state that that
has lost a lot of money that's a big
city no it is a big state city or state
it's a big state I guess West Virginia
already okay I'm gonna go to Texas okay
go for it click on it zoom in it's
Nevada oh Nevada's five percent go up no
no go up in the bottom no no the other
way the other way yeah right there zoom
in right there wow Nevada is like 5.2
percent guys DC's 4.7 Illinois 47 Oregon
4-5 Delaware 4-4 and by the way go up to
Washington
Middle word that one guy if you can go
back there you go is Delaware that one
place where that guy lost his job who
got a hold of that laptop
that's Delaware right yeah it's probably
affecting that but keep going down
his dad's taking care of I mean you've
caused the lowest
decoders are the next and it's Florida
huh yeah let's go it's a round of
applause
by the way this is the stuff that
Governor Ron DeSantis can use when he's
running to say out of the we are the
number four lowest unemployment rate in
America say something yeah
in America interesting to see this data
how are you processing Nevada almost
double where it is it's entertainment
think about the population means North
Dakota South Dakota and Utah I mean
probably my sister was stationed and
there's a bunch of military bases there
I'm wondering if that you know if
there's a base I will tell you this
about Nevada though like we just signed
we're doing our next MGM event in August
right and we get the whole MGM Grand
Arena here's what happened
we just we aren't right now negotiating
for the next couple years two or three
years to sign with them and by the way
they're booked for four years
did you hear what I said MGM Grand Arena
Convention Center is booked for four
years insane so meaning I I convention
businesses back
so it's interesting you're saying why is
Nevada's on can you Google why is
Nevada's unemployment rate the highest
why is Nevada's unemployment rate the
highest what would it be is and so Pat
they do an event like some MGM does an
event every weekend oh is that what
they're doing also their book for God
that's insane why why is it about as
Nevada's on the planet jumps 4.9 to the
states also saw the large one in Las
Vegas this housing market has cooled
amid Rising Hydro okay so what does that
have to unemployment zoom in now what's
on unemployment the state also has the
largest increase from October 0.30 along
with Oregon Department of Labor Nevada's
economy still recovering from a step
down turn a massive job loss so during
the first ever pandemic the key Hotel
entertainment in this in the industry in
Las Vegas has bounced back as gamblers
already returning okay great but the
city's real estate market is as cooled
along with other hot spots amid a sharp
increase in interest rates property
manners in Las Vegas are seen more
available rentals I have I have a theory
as as you're reading this because you
talked about the convention let's go to
the Chart okay they're just recovering
is what it is so it's not up to four
nines
so they're like we're happy to be at the
number we are today well I think that
you're telling me about the convention
business there's a difference between
like corporations and people just the
average working person corporations big
events everything that we do now but all
massive events
that they're doing okay they're back to
business that's business as normal but
the average person out there isn't
exactly balling out in Vegas these days
with inflation and interest rates right
now so they're a little bit more
struggling versus what all the free
money was being printed that's how I'm
processing these numbers and uh for
people at home now but is
yeah it's a great conference you know
for them to know about the insurance
conference now but it's like uh one of
the bigger like real estate does their
biggest conferences this is one of
Insurance's biggest conferences that
they do but again so this isn't really
the fact that Nevada is taking a hit
Nevada is just getting back into the
convention business all I'm saying to
you is study that five percent
unemployment number that's the number I
would be looking at in my market to look
at whether it's time to buy a house or
not Rob do we go to the next sponsor or
do we do the car first I say we do
carves because it has to be in the first
six minutes 30 minutes right or is it 25
minutes first 30 but okay 9 24. I'm just
gonna do it right now for the sake of it
so watch this you guys heard me earlier
when I talked about that collectible
card uh Wayne Gretzky card that we
bought for 540 and sold it for 2.2
million I'll never forget it's 11th or
it's midnight Jen's laying next to me
and I said babe
it's just babe I'm sleeping I said babe
do you remember that those cards I
bought for 5 40. she says yeah what
about it I said I just sold it for 2.2
million and she says what did you just
say I said 2.2 million in 18 months wow
from 540 to 2.2 million that same Cart
six months later sold for 3.75 million
do you know why because cards and art
people didn't trust cards and art it's
been said that art 80 of it has been
what has been fraught and card there's
been a lot of fraud because it would cut
the sides and all this stuff what change
collectible cards as well as art is
companies like Masterworks like PSA
Masterworks that we decided to team up
with to make our sponsors has become an
alternative investment for people to
consider when you look at Art I can give
you a lot of different data when it
comes down to Art Goldman Sachs and
BlackRock say the days of uh there's no
alternative investment are over Ria
reports 88 of surveyed advisors intend
to increase allocations to Alternatives
over the next two years with over half
which is 53 raising allocations all the
way to 15 of your allocations going in
alternative Investments
so if you may be watching the same same
pattern I can't afford a bank see I
can't afford a Picasso I don't know if
they're right or wrong don't worry about
that don't worry about that what
Masterworks does is they go do all the
verification they deal directly with the
SEC every single thing you buy with them
it's qualified with the SEC and it's
broken into share so if a bank see piece
is two million dollars and you can't
afford to buy it for two million dollars
but you can invest twenty thousand
dollars you can own a share of Banksy
art now or a piece of Pablo Picasso art
now and we see the numbers when you see
what's going on with art so Masterworks
last three exits have delivered 17 21
and 33 percent of net returns net
returns so having said that they have
nearly 600 000 members and paintings
have sold out in minutes but you can get
Priority Access to be part of a
Masterworks as long as you're part of
valuetainment it's By Invitation Only
there's going to be a link below if you
do want to participate in art as an
alternate alternative investment you may
want to look into Masterworks Rob let's
make sure to put their links below for
them to request an invitation to be part
of the other six hundred thousand
members so having said that let's go
into cars I want to talk about cars here
I saw some data this morning and it was
really interesting okay folks if I can
tell you to subscribe to anything today
go subscribe to Wall Street Journal we
don't make money off of it go subscribe
to what they're saying with their tweet
their uh newspaper I still get newspaper
I go to this restaurant this lady told
me I can't see the thing about the last
time I saw a man reading a newspaper and
I think she was trying to say I'm
getting older yeah because I like
newspapers subscribe to their article
subscribe to their newspapers the
content they're making right now is so
Center which is what we need they're not
Fox they'll call out Trump they'll call
out the Santas they're not CNN
they'll call out Biden they'll call out
the administration they're who you want
to talk to they're doing a phenomenal
job today uh Wall Street journalist so I
saw this video if you can pull up this
video by the way that I sent you and on
Wall Street Journal this video shows a
guy who owns a dealership what it look
like just a few months ago versus today
watch how he describes this turn on
there you go go ahead
and you look
everything you see is new that's 10 rows
each with about 15 cars it's probably
150 175 cars it's what you'd expect to
see at a car dealership like Adam Lee's
but let's rewind eight months oh I
walked out here in a while this is they
don't have any cars wow last year new
car sales fell to their lowest level in
over a decade as Shoppers saw more
asphalt than cars on dealer Lots there
is no cars according to today dealers
like Adam Lee finally have more cars to
sell But Rising interest rates are
making those cars harder to afford okay
you can pause it right here so there's a
couple things when I saw this video and
a couple charts that I wanted to share
with you so first of all we all know a
year ago I'm trying to buy a car for my
family for my you can't get a car you
can't get chips the prices are
ridiculous then you see some of these
numbers go to the next chart that
they're showing based on Auto Sales okay
so this is inventory okay inventory for
about two years America for the first
time ever we're talking to since decades
our inventory was less than a million
prior to covet look at 2020 if you look
at 2020 you see that number three
million prior to 2020 the American
dealerships dealerships in America for
decades were always above 3 million we
always had three million cars in
inventory for decades it dropped to less
than a million you see that number right
there 788 which was July of 2022 it's
come up to 1.172 million it still hasn't
come out we got a lot of room to come up
to uh what do you call it the average of
3 million plus can you go to the next
chart which was kind of interesting to
think about this is the number of day
supplies automakers have jeep has enough
supply for 125 days Jeep
can you zoom in a little closely to see
who's second third if we can see it okay
number two is that Buick Buick Buick
Volvo Chrysler well Buick should have
enough supply for years uh Volvo
Chrysler Dodge Jaguar Ram Infinity okay
go to the Bottom now go to the bottom
all the way at the bottom is Toyota can
you go to the next slide so we know what
Toyota's days are so that's 152 Toyota
only has 27.7 days of Supply wow which
means Toyota Kia Honda Lexus is selling
even Land Rover BMW selling so Porsche
is selling that's a Mercedes is selling
faster than Buick so go to the next
slide go to the next slide that we have
here average new vehicle transaction
price go three years ago 32 000 the
average car today Vinnie is forty seven
thousand dollars honestly Tom how the
hell are people making these car
payments by the way here's how I want
you to look at this this is the thought
that was scary for me can you go do me a
favor pull up a a calculator just pull
up a calculator uh uh uh car auto
payment calculator type in auto car
payment calculator I see where you're
going I'd also like to know how many
months the average number of months
people are on those car loans they used
to be 65 years I'm wondering if they're
going longer because the car's more
expensive why don't we do this together
let's just do this together go to auto
loan calculator zoom in a little bit put
32 000 price 32 000 stay on six months
go to what were the rates uh three years
ago in 2019 one percent two percent what
do you want to put a time you could get
three let's just use three average
credit three percent okay put three
percent down payment let's put zero
we're putting zero down payment yeah
okay and then pick State I don't know go
to Florida let's just do Florida to
Florida okay uh or matter of fact go to
California go to California go to
California okay go to California
whatever is fine calculate
calculate
what's the payment 575 where do you see
it 575 is a payment okay so that's what
that's at the average price of a car
three years ago which was 32k okay and
we're using three percent interest rate
payment is 575. no money down which is
no money down fine now go to take that
take that 32 000 make it forty seven
thousand
leave the time what do you want to put
it at seven percent or six and a half
let's just use six and a half go to six
and a half everything stays the same
calculate
9 19. so let me get this straight it's
like two cars you went from 575 to 919
the income hasn't increased no your
income hasn't what is the number on that
575 on 919 if we do the math is that an
increase of a 70 percent Jesus 919 minus
575 345 divided by 575. that's 60
increase in car payments in three years
Vinnie oh my God in three years we're
not in four years we're not talking
about an increase by the way meanwhile
all those money that they spent to
people they've spent okay so so when
people are like well America's gonna be
fine real estate's gonna be fine economy
is going to be fine really the only way
this is going to be fine is what's the
average income in America in 2019 pull
up average income in America in 2019
what is the median income whatever you
want to not households individual
individual income in 2019 individual
income is probably closer to 40 Grand
fine no problem let's use household
ghost household income in 2019 at 68
what's household income today what's
household income in 2023 what is a show
60 wait how much
74.75 okay so let's do the math here
here's why I want you to know problem is
coming because the American family is
going to feel this so that's an increase
of seven thousand dollars seven thousand
dollars so their income has increased
ten percent but the average car payment
has increased 60 percent you explained
to me how American families are going to
make up that 50 like this there's only a
couple things that happens layoffs or a
big ass increases of fifty percent
companies cannot pay 50 increase today
so what's gonna happen next
Auto auto selling of cars prices of cars
are going to go down okay you're gonna
see people who are trying to sell their
homes it's gonna go down this is bigger
than people think as much as we talk
about home prices
what do you think people buy more of
cars or homes cars the first way to
judge if people can afford to buy houses
if they can't afford to buy what a car
yeah so if they can't afford to buy a
car today how in the hell are they going
to buy a house today and then what is
the seller going to do doesn't the
seller need more qualified buyers guess
what qualified buyers are decreasing
qualified buyers are decreasing so this
is a very interesting season we're going
to go into the next six 12 months if you
own your car today uh uh good for you if
you're about to go buy a car today brace
for impact you're going to see it in the
payments if you haven't already if you
haven't already Tom you're doing some
math or so I'm curious on what you're
thinking I did average length of a car
loan 2019
59.5 months six years
60. average length today
69.7 months almost 70. ladies and
gentlemen 72 is one more year so the how
is Americans dealing with it
if Rob could go back there and plug in
72 months
just plug in 72 on the 47. and I'm all
happy is Adam because Adam does not have
a car this whole time
now take a look it's still seven nine do
me a favor matter of fact let's play
this game go to 84 which is seven years
go to 84. by the way the longer you go
the higher the increase the rates but
it's fine go to 84 it's worse
697 go to 96. Jesus to get to the same
payment go to 108. oh my God we're gonna
play this game go to 108. what was the
number 575 you're officially at it
instead of 60 payments of 575 to afford
today's car you have to make an
additional 48 payments yeah but how much
is the cost gone up how much more
interest are you paying that's the
number that doesn't matter the average
family doesn't think about interest they
think what they can afford on a monthly
payment yeah but that's the exact
opposite well you should be it's not
about what you should be Adam we're not
sitting here talking about what people
should be doing the average family
sitting there saying I need a freaking
SUV I need something I can only afford
575. they don't care about interest
rates when I bought my first Mitsubishi
Eclipse when I was in the Army you know
what my interest rate was F Mac if
you're listening Fu 33 yeah 33 FM
of Kentucky Clarksville if you're out
there I don't know if you're still in
business they gave this 18 year old kid
a Mitsubishi Eclipse 33 percent of my
interest rate I paid it Jesus forget it
was a 5300 loan but it took me I'm still
paying I'm still paying it yesterday was
your last time outside
that's right one of the tires is missing
you know we push it every morning when
we come here you can't say that people
can't care about the interest rates I
didn't tell you that no Adam okay you
care I care yes we care yes people care
more about the payment than the interest
rate and that's why they're idiots
that's why most people are living
paycheck paycheck and they can't afford
I didn't tell you whether they're idiots
or not they listen to this contest could
they want to change yeah they listen to
songs because they want to change the
people that are listening to you they're
saying I agree with you I want to learn
from you but the average person today
who is the majority is only looking at
payment and guess how they're going to
be financing you know what John can you
by any chance make it 108 months can you
buy any chance make it 96 the sales
person doesn't say Well Mr Jones do you
really realize how much more interest
you're going to pick the sales person
like I don't care what we make it sell
it so I can make my commission yeah so
this car salesman we all know that the
big money in cars just as you're seeing
this is not on buying the car it's the
financing that's how they can go from
making two three five grand to 20 grand
off of Customer because if a customer is
like I just want to be at a 400 payment
it's like all right well get ready to
make those 400 payments for the next 30
Years buddy let me read a couple quick
super chats here one is Scott Rodriguez
by the way I think by the end of March
starting April we're only going to have
members be able to comment a lot of
people are becoming members if you
haven't yet become a member you may want
to starting April we will only be
reading uh members will only be able to
see their comments everybody else you
won't be seen in April but you got a
month to become a member Scott said and
I'm going to say this in the friendliest
way good morning Home Team the live show
was amazing by the way we had a sick
event last week live it was phenomenal I
had a great time tip take uh take
takeaways from the live show Peabody is
a stallion I don't know what that means
bizdoc is an OG Vinnie is one handsome
stud and Adam definitely looks his age
why is everybody
like not even one good compliment not
cool man but hey Scott I enjoyed talking
to you're an absolute stud of a guy
Jesse just commented uh gave a Super
Chat I've been selling cdjr for six
years now sales have a lot to do with
your team and the industry is filtering
out the Layman average salesman that got
in these last three years and didn't
sharpen their skills and relationship
Jesse I agree the same is in many
different Industries these are different
times relationship matters a lot in
Industry today so Tom before we go into
the next story any final thoughts on the
cards or can we go to the next one no
let's go to the next story I think we've
uh I think we've run that one now out of
my lap leak lab leak lab
[Laughter]
trust me you're in that category you got
nothing to worry about all right when I
tell you I'm not wearing lab I'm not
worried by the way just so you guys know
he was worried can I we texted the
camera to go off his eye because he was
crying so it's okay it's going to be
split it up yeah it was very quick so
lab leak
lab Elite most like the origin of
covid-19 pandemic energy department now
says this is a Wall Street Journal story
when this was said people lost their
minds how dare you tell me racist I made
the wrong decision following fauci and
science how dare you do something like
that well the U.S energy department has
concluded with low confidence that the
covet pandemic most likely erodes from a
laboratory League to conclusion is the
result of new intelligence and is
significant because the agency has
considerable scientific expertise and
oversees a network of U.S National
Laboratories some of which conduct
Advanced biological research the FBI
previously came to the conclusion that
the pandemic was likely the result of a
lab leak in 2021 with moderate
confidence and it still holds this view
the energy department now joins the
event saying the virus likely spread via
a mishap at a Chinese laboratory China
which has placed limits on
investigations by the World Health
Organization has disputed that the virus
could have a leak from one of its labs
and as suggested it emerged outside of
China
do you hear what you're saying the low
confidence moderate confidence and I
hate when people say stuff like man I
hate to say I told you so I don't like I
don't know if I'm a I'm a psychic or or
what's going on with me Pat and I'm
pretty sure you're in the same camp we
were all right we were right about the
lab League we were right about natural
immunity we were right about the mask we
were right about lockdowns we were right
about the vaccines the boosters
Ivermectin Dr fauci being a little rat
the who like how am I just so right
about all this like do I have a crystal
ball like how do we know but all these
people did it and the fact that they're
still coming up was I think it was John
Kirby yesterday Pat he comes out and
he's like because somebody from I'm
shocked that they asked them they're
like how do you guys feel about the gain
of function Richards are you guys doing
it he said it's necessary for us to now
they're saying that yes we we do
um gain a function but we have to figure
out this next step and I sent Rob this
link Rob on on slack I'm worried Pat
because Joe Biden said eight months ago
I think almost a year ago he goes hey
guys we need the money for all this and
all that because a second pandemic is
coming Joe Biden said that verbatim and
it scares me back because we had people
like uh Leeming Dr Yemen uh uh young she
was on uh Tucker Carlson last night she
worked for the Chinese uh government and
she said this was she's this is a doctor
Pat this is not just a regular citizen
that I had to run I had around two and a
half years ago okay so you know and what
did she say years ago she goes the
government leaked this to destroy the
economy we got a strike for that and
they took it down within 48 hours and
you remember that virologist yep you got
a strike and they took it out within 48
hours and so think and so and going to
my next Point yeah doesn't that scare
that should scare the average American
that this all came out China is so
protected by our media by our government
and I just it just goes to me to ask the
question why what hold on Tom why why is
it because we owe them all this money is
it because they they know certain things
about it like can you somebody make make
it make sense to me how why you know you
know what you know what I think is
needed Tom
do you know uh that uh movie Aaron
Brockovich is that the movie Aaron Brock
yes it's the story I mean obviously
Julia Roberts but what is the story
about the story is about uh chromium
which is a there's a chromium chemical
that was used to help lubricate pumps at
water uh treatment and water pumps that
was in um in desert community in
California that chromium at a certain
percentage caused tremendous Cancers and
sterility as and uterine problems in the
people and Erin Brockovich and another
attorney went out there and discovered
that they had covered up the spills in
the disposal of the chromium yeah and so
Aaron Brockovich brought it to light and
who was Aaron Brockovich Aaron
Brockovich was basically a paralegal
that had the guts to go out and do the
research and she partnered with a law
firm and you can read the true story of
her well covered by the LA Times I don't
usually give them credit but they've
written a lot of stories about the real
Erin Brockovich and the real story she
was a whistleblower so here's what she
ended up doing right she went up against
the most powerful people a case against
Pacific Gas and Electric Company which
is basically a government entity exactly
California and involving groundwater
contamination in Hinckley California and
did she end up winning did she end up
exposing them did lobbyists lose their
minds did they have to settle for 333
million dollars the largest settlement
ever paid in a direct action lawsuit in
the United States history to that date
yes she did that you know what's needed
today what's needed today is one of
these Relentless
lawyers who is not going to give up
until they get to the bottom of it I
don't want to say the following line
that many of us have said including
myself you think they're ever going to
be held accountable no they're not I
don't want to say that I'm convinced
somebody lost a relative a family
based on the decision that was made it's
going to spend and dedicate the rest of
their lives to proving all the stupid
things that they did Force manipulate
and that person is going to dedicate
their lives to it until we find out
about it I think the the market today
just think about this was a niche market
in California we're not talking about a
huge yeah we're talking about and this
ended up becoming a national thing right
we're talking covet that came from China
that the president said the China virus
and the lady says you can't call a China
virus why do they call it China of arts
and he said because it came from China
China the flu called the Spanish flu
it's not offensive when they say the
Spanish flu because that's where it came
from so moving forward everybody has to
start calling it The China virus this is
that somebody I believe that's a True
Believer is going to go investigate this
and then all of a sudden they're going
to say holy [__] if a True Believer if
the True Believers rise up and go out
there and do this it's going to be a
scary sight for a lot of people yeah I
feel like we're living in reality
programming and this is a Netflix
special called covid confessions and
we're in the middle of season one
episode six masks don't really work the
the virus did come from a lab in China
you know the vaccine will not prevent
you from getting it the vaccine has side
effects my goodness I just feel like
we're in covid confessions season one
episode six and it just keeps going but
it really makes me nervous about because
we know why do we get flu shots back in
the day each year because the flu
runs around the globe the normal annual
flu runs around the globe and because
you have winter in the southern
hemisphere winter and Northern
Hemisphere starts Australia comes up to
us they know what the strains are going
to be and you're going to get your
simple little 15 flu shot
these things influenza and flu-like
viruses and I'm not an epidemiologist or
anything but
the next version of it you know is
usually tougher and so I just this part
of it makes me nervous but the front
part of it makes me disgusted because I
think we every week there's some sort of
a discussion
by the way can you pull up what I just
said I think this highlights exactly
what we stand for here is the concept of
open discussion and debate so for years
if you had an opinion nobody knew for
sure like I sure like I agree no matter
what you say you didn't know for sure
you had an opinion but you're entitled
to your opinion the problem is what
happened with big Tech and collusion
with the government is that they shut
down opinions they shut down discourse
you were Shadow banned you were flagged
you were censored you were striked
um you were potentially canceled for
expressing an an opinion okay and I'm
highlighting that opinion here I love
that and that is exactly what we stand
for here is like you tried to set up a
debate with two different types of
doctors and one wouldn't come on pretty
prominent doctor because he didn't want
to go against The Narrative of the uh
basically the bat versus the lab
situation yeah one with Dr Mike yeah
who's a famous YouTuber the other one
was Dr Paul office Dr Mike agreed to
come three times he said yes yes yes
then he said he's busy and then he made
it 50 other videos two weeks later and
as busy as he was he was not busy he was
frightened yes he was afraid is what he
was and every other week fauci would be
on his YouTube channel so God forbid if
he was disloyal to fauci and the CDC Dr
Mike is not somebody who uh uh was
willing to sit down and have a real
educated debate with another qualified
doctor with a nice resume of Stanford
Harvard educated no because anybody that
disagreed with uh uh fauci was not
really they really didn't trust science
that's what they've given a platform
that a lot of people on those things
including Robert Kennedy I mean so the
invitation's been open to come have pbd
moderate you know productive debate
between people and and you've you've
spoken you've had interviews with Robert
Kennedy and others yeah but here's my
question too about what why and I'm
going to keep saying why why is the
government so low moderate they don't
want to point out at China and why does
the government the government and fauci
still have that stance they got skin in
the game that lab we were sending money
our government with fauci right with the
equal Health Alliance I guess to do gain
a function and it leaked they have skin
in the game they have to be like well we
kind of it's not it's not going to be a
definite point but we're not stupid we
get it you know what I mean but like you
said it's gonna take one person hope to
God to be like okay listen enough is
enough point the fingers still to this
day you mean three years later I can't
say it came from China do they own us
that much that I can't say it a lot I
think without being racist or conspiracy
theorists because on the way here Pat I
watched like eight videos of Just MSNBC
and everybody going Trump whatever what
a race what a racist divisive and if we
let him say China and call the China
virus I don't give a [__] maybe we'd be
you know we'd be closer to finding out
hey who leaked it who's the person that
lab doesn't have hundreds of thousands
of people how many of you people were in
there which one of you did it and why
who the hell are you do you have ties to
anybody if we don't get to that that
point it's gonna happen again just like
Joe Biden said it's going to happen
again and Rob at one point could play
that video the president United States
said eight months ago another pandemic
is coming can you play Pat this is this
is Joe Biden eight months ago saying he
needs more money and this is what he
said about another pandemic watch we do
need more money is it we don't just need
more money for vaccines for children
eventually we need more money to plan
for the second pandemic there's going to
be another pandemic we have to think
ahead what and that's not something is
this psychic how do you know a second
pandemic is coming really well that's
why you can stop how does he know how do
you know I I don't I mean because we've
had Ebola and SARS yeah things occurs so
it's not I'm not they're not back to
back I'm not gonna go conspiracy theory
they're not planning the next page no no
I didn't say he's planning I'm saying
how does he know hold on don't I hate
when you do this conspiracy [__] it
ain't a conspiracy he pandemics don't
happen every year Adam they happen in 10
years and 20 when's the last pandemic
was it 2001 Global 100 years ago but if
you're talking about SARS and Ebola 2001
2001 Obama but how does how do you how
can you say what's your point my point
is he's there if we don't get to the
root of it and say okay this is what
happened because we're scared about
offending a country that I don't give a
[__] about who gives a [__] well then
now I agree with you okay if you want to
get to the point let's get to the point
thank you the point is this yes China
needs to be held account a period okay
seven seven million dead that's where
I'm going with it okay I'm not going to
yeah I got to you know all different
sorts of places so the problem with
trying to Pat hit the nail on the head
with the Aaron Brockovich thing China
has denied denied denied they've covered
up they've been uh not not cooperating
with any of the organizations they're
not letting people in there to to
basically find out exactly what happened
here and in any unsolved mystery you
want to know what the hell happened who
did it what's the reason why now
intelligence 80s uh agencies committees
have
with confidence have basically said that
it is that is a lab mishap not a Act of
aggression or a bio weapon purposely put
out there but why would China want to
basically promote more of the bat Theory
than the lab Theory because if it is the
lab Theory
they are 100 accountable because that's
a government agency within China part of
the government if it is the bat Theory
bats [__] fly it could have come from
anywhere mongolia's Korea whatever one
of those things one of those things that
happened to be here some hungry Chinese
guys saw the bat that flew in took a
bite out of its head in a wet Market
it's easier to kind of maneuver your way
out of that so that's China's premise
but at the end of the day I'm not going
wild conspiratorial thing here what I do
want to find out much like you is what
exactly happened with China and get some
answers yeah because the end of the day
and here's the biggest thing is
how much money was printed how many
lives were lost how many potential
lawsuits Global lawsuits could be held
liable against China China yeah seven
million people died globally and it
wasn't that whole story they said it was
a Pangolin in this market pangolin's a
mammal it's not even a Tom were you
going to say something or or can we okay
let's go to this next thing here if you
can do me a favor
so Woody Harrison okay Woody Harrelson
who was the actor from a lot of
different movies he was in white man can
jump I don't know
it's just a great actor man he was a and
a lot of different he wasn't too anyways
played the clip on what he just said on
SNL and then people's reaction I'm gonna
send you something to show how the
entire media reacted to this go for it
okay so the movie goes like this
the biggest drug cartels in the world
get together and buy up all the media
and all the politicians and force all
the people in the world stay locked in
their homes and people can only come out
if they take the cartels drugs and keep
taking them over and over wow I threw
the script away I mean who is gonna
believe that crazy idea okay
now do me a favor show or show what I
just texted to you and show how the
market reacted immediately after that
SNL went live you have to see what these
guys said if you can put this up I'll
give you just three stories if you can
just pull these things up you know oh
he's he's out of his mind he has no clue
what he's talking about go ahead and
make that bigger check this out uh uh
see if we can open it up boom check this
out Woody Harrison uh Saturday Night
Live monologue makes covet conspiracy
jokes variety it's a rolling stone Woody
Harrelson spreads anti-vaxx conspiracy
during SNL Monologue huffpo Woody
Harrelson Rambles about weed and
anti-vaxx conspiracy
can you imagine this is a guy that is in
Hollywood he's a product of your
industry which by the way when I saw him
talk about what he said here do you
remember Woody Harrelson in the movie
2012 where he was a conspiracy theorist
on the top of the mountain saying the
end of the world is coming yeah do you
guys remember that whole thing of course
that's the first thing I thought of I'm
like did this guy if if the media really
wanted to do a good job taking a shot at
him they would Play a clip and saying he
hasn't left this movie yet he's still a
conspiracy theorist from the movie but
they didn't do that but they missed the
mark anyways when you saw something like
this but it was the first thing you
thought about first first Pat hilarious
ballsy because think about it you're in
one of the most liberal cities on the
one of the most biased left-leaning
shows I wanted to ask you guys and how
to maybe you could even ask Marcelo do
they have to approve your monologue he's
reading it off a teleprompter the fact I
mean the fact that they're always always
left-leaning good on them for going you
know what the hell with it go do it it
might help with with um with viewership
but if you think about it bro I I
commend people like that that take their
platform to kind of poke fun to make
like but make their point as well and
what what a perfect time especially when
all this lab leak crap is coming this
was last Saturday Pat this is the most
recent one I say good for him I'm
curious to see I want to know what
happened maybe somebody in his family or
something happened with his life or how
his career is going to be effect there's
another clip with him and Bill Maher
maybe I'll just find that one on Twitter
we'll go ahead Adam what do you think
about when you see this I'm just
wondering if a retraction or apology is
coming soon yeah you might be like I
misspoke this was on different uh I was
smoking a lot of weed yeah but I think
one thing we can all agree upon I I
again I'm not the conspiracy theory guy
what what I what I what I will say is
I'm very comfortable calling out big
Pharma because there's no money made in
immunity like there's no money to be
made in let's just naturally immunize uh
and just go from there how much how many
billions of dollars did they make from
vaccines so to me calling out big Pharma
uh there's nothing wrong with that at
the same time you know not everything
big Pharma does is bad you know that's
that that would be sort of disingenuous
they they do provide drugs that do save
people's lives Cancer Treatments
diabetes the list goes on and on but
there's there's no doubt this kind of
leads to a bigger question of whether
you know Health Care should be
nationalized or whether it should be
um basically a for-profit organizations
like this but it's fully in the right if
we just establish anything to have this
conversation to have this debate if
there's anything we've learned shutting
down one side's opinion is a road to
nowhere okay and that's where censorship
and communism sort of shows up and
that's not what America is so hopefully
I'm not guaranteeing it hopefully we've
at least as a society are starting to
learn our lesson that not shutting down
opinions uh is the way to go
[Music]
it sounded like Adam's about to run for
local city council or mayor or Congress
or Senator but go ahead go ahead Adam
actually before we go my mom's my mom
text me this right now tell Adam I think
he looks great that Sanchez guy is crazy
and he's a nice guy after the show I
love you all that's my mom that's right
Mom thank you no I think I think
it was a really gutsy move and whoever
wrote that monologue is equally gutsy
and whoever green lit it is also gutsy
and they're letting the blowback come to
Woody Harrelson yeah and unless you
completely go off script uh Saturday
Night Live is
produced and there's a producer and they
do edgy things with monologues and they
play off the uh personalities that are
kind of say one more thing about SNL do
that because because Tom if it is an SNL
Monologue then then let's see what he
said to Bill Marcus this is definitely
not a monologue so why don't you play
this real quick and then Adam let me
hear what you got to say yeah I
definitely want to hear that this is the
CDC promoting that we have to do all of
these things right I just I don't like
profiteering in war you know think of
the billions of dollars that have gone
to Big Pharma but I was getting back to
my original point the last people I
would trust with my health is Big Pharma
and big government because neither one
of those what strike me as caring in
place spoken as the perfect redneck
hippie
if that message doesn't mean it's all
about profit exactly you're all about
profit and both sides I've seen the
profit they made I think they've done a
lot of studies about vitamin D and how
important it was when the people who had
low levels they were much more
why not tell people that can't you make
money selling vitamin D is it that kind
of what's the worst that could happen
that's just it man there was only one
thing you know I remember Mac didn't got
made into a you know horse tranquilizer
uh a horse whatever it is which it is
but also used by humans if you'd use my
millions and millions of years uh uh
hydroxychloroquine got uh made
ridiculous
um and there was only one thing that
could work and that's the vaccine right
and so ultimately because of that
billions of dollars was made right oh
you know the drinking on that show too
that's Woody loose his shoes are off
he's playing with his feet and he's just
telling you how it is they're definitely
smoking some weed 100 is one manager
called them afterwards saying Woody what
was that I just got a call you were
gonna be on Transformers 28 and you're
done
oh my God you were gonna say something
well
I was gonna say something about SNL just
because what we've seen as of late is
there again there's this return to
normalcy covet has made everyone go
insane and Donald Trump prior to that
has made a lot a lot of people on the
left lose their freaking mind we're all
familiar with Trump derangement syndrome
so who played uh Trump on SNL for all
those years Alec Baldwin anything
happened to Alec Baldwin as of late is
he in the middle as of late lately
anyone to get murdered by Alex Baldwin
as of late so if you see what's
happening with Woody Harrelson you're
right this was script they knew this was
happening a month ago you had Dave
Chappelle say some wild ass [__] what's
happening is just like how CNN who's
their new uh uh CEO Chris Licht like
okay a lot of these liberal left-leaning
establishments are basically saying
listen guys
can't just go to one audience and
eventually Jimmy Kimmel is gonna have to
Veer right same with Fallon same with
Colbert you can't just do the same
shtick it gets old so kudos to SNL for
at least uh going down a path of calling
out both sides which they used to do
right kudos to CNN for even covering the
uh the thing that happened in Ohio they
did it way more than Fox did so you can
either learn from what happened or
double down on what happened and I I
like to see
Outlets that are traditionally only
left-leaning at least Embrace other
opinions that's a step in the right
direction call me diplomatic call me
what you will I'd like to see I also put
a my media hat on and I think about it
that somewhere inside SNL this week and
it says well he's taking the heat but
the phrase SNL Monologue is in the
headlines and I hope people tune in next
week to watch 100 whereas Chris Licht is
actually trying to get ratings back
rather unsuccessfully and he's had
people like Don Lemon you know have his
issues but at SNL I think they took a
bet I think a producer said all right
let's give it a try and I think they're
kind of happy about it because
Harrelson's getting the uh the Heat and
they got a little publicity and says hey
big things happen on SNL tune in next
week and come check out
by the way before we go away from this
story this is a 2012 article so this has
nothing to do with politics this is
under Obama
and this uh Kaylee rkl writes this
article 12 diseases in the lucky places
they're named for go let's look at some
of these 12 places
uh number one uh uh Guinea warm sounds
like a Italian color no no no that's by
the way that's almost been eradicated by
the efforts of the Carter uh Foundation
okay so the next one is West Nile Virus
German Measles keep going racism Ross
River fever races
Ebola hemorrhagic fever
Marburg virus disease Lassa fever
lacrosse
Encephalitis Encephalitis okay St Louis
Encephalitis Rocky Mountain Spotted
Fever Lyme disease and Spanish Flu by
the way they don't know if it's really
from uh Spain or if it's from France or
Italy it's a debate so they don't 100
off at Spanish from Spain or not to
correct that the point is hey a lot of
yes named after the location
normal to uh uh name the you know a
virus from where it's at so maybe by the
time this is over they're going to
finally name it properly I never fully
got that as to why it was racist to call
it from China I never got it well
because like like Trump or not it
originated in China I didn't understand
why that was so controversial I think
that was my point because like I said
the government and falching do they had
to make it races even China came on they
were like that's racist because bro they
all got skin in the game I'm telling you
fauci our government because dude
imagine this one day you find out hey
this thing that's going to be killing a
million of us millions of us came from a
lab in a country that were you know we
have beef and we're paying for it you
got to be like no no don't look over
here Ray says I just racist is such a
watered-down term that just gets thrown
out like left and right these days oh
that again we're looking for
accountability Here China and if it
originated in a lab or even in a bat in
your wet market like it originated in
China yeah so all right let's go to the
next door let's go to Governor DeSantis
says ex Disney seal complaint of
pressure over school Bill uh that they
had so let's take a look at this so in
early 2022 former Disney Bob shape had
contacted Governor Ron descendants to
express his concern over Florida's no
education bill that bans the teaching of
gender identity to young children
DeSantis revealed details of the
conversation the chapter of his new
Memoir uh oh why do people write Memoirs
it's interesting when they write it it's
typically before they make a big
decision the courage to be free
Florida's blueprint for American Revival
chapek reportedly told the Santas that
he was getting a lot of pressure away
to wane against the bill stating we get
pressured all the time but this time is
different I haven't seen anything like
this before the parental rights and
education bill which was passed in March
of 2022 prohibits teachers from
discussing sexual orientation or gender
identity in kindergarten through their
third grade shapeac expresses opinion to
the bill stating that if it were to be
passed it could be used to unfairly
Target gay lesbian non-binary
transgender kids and families the
scientists wrote ultimately Bob shepak
and Disney cave to the leftist media and
activists pressure impressed a false
narrative uh against the bill which by
the way that leads to the next Story New
York Governor de Santa signs Bill
placing Disney District under State
Control this is a February 27th story
just yesterday he assigned a bill that
rebrands Disney self-governed really
Creek improvement district as the
central Florida tourism oversight
District which will now be under the
state control ending Disney's near
autonomous control over the area the
bill gives the santis the power to
appoint the members of a 5 an oversight
board for the special district which was
previously held by Disney the center
stated that the move will bring
accountability to distance operation in
the district and that it would not lead
to any additional tax burden on
Floridians the move comes after a
month-long feud between the census and
Disney over the states don't say Gable
law which bars discussions of gender
identity etc etc go ahead Adam thoughts
on the story well I'm going to give the
Santa's praise and then maybe some
criticism here uh I've been pretty vocal
that I'm definitely more supportive of
him than other candidates that are
potentially running on the right
um
I think everything comes down to Optics
I mean if the the bill was called the
parental rights of Education Bill and
then when it came out to marketing or
backlash against the bill it somehow
turned into the don't say gay bill
that's not the name of the bill and you
know I don't have kids but I I'm pretty
open that I I'm very active in the role
of my nephew and
you know I don't want kindergarteners
learning about gender and identity this
is not anything that is apparent that I
would want my kids even discussing in
kindergarten it's not anything that I
think is inappropriate and I think it's
actually
um spot on by why you would want to do
this but also what what Ron DeSantis and
I think it's worked for him I don't know
if it's gonna backfire
he is leading the league and going in
the culture wars you know with with uh
the don't say gay stuff the LGBT stuff
the woke stuff this is where woke goes
to die critical race Theory that's the
Santa's Playbook he's going against the
left in that in that ideology and that's
great here's my concern Pat so when you
read that second story about placing
bills placing uh placing Disney under
under State Control
I don't know when I hear the term under
State control that seems very uh
government overreach not free market
approach that Republicans have basically
prided themselves on since pre-regan
days so I'm wondering if that is going
to come under some sort of backlash that
to me is not the free enterprise and
freedom which he has basically made his
name on so I think at the end of the day
he needs to have a sit down with Bob
Iger who's the new acting CEO of Disney
it's no longer the jpac guy and figure
this out because uh once you become on
the national stage and do run for
president uh I don't know if this is
going to be a winning battle to go
against Disney
well this has been coming for a while so
let's step back to something you just
summarized there and let me offer
another perspective
the
the area the Reedy Creek improvement
district Once Upon a Time Disney took
this massive piece of Florida property
and developed it for theme parks and we
all know where it was Disney World and
then Epcot and all the things that are
around there and it managed that area
roads and all this kind of stuff were
managed by Disney it also got tax
benefit
s this what Disney is being told is hey
Florida's going to manage this the same
way we manage the land and the byways
and highways and streets and the rest of
the city and you don't have your
autonomous control over what goes happen
in the area and we're going to take a
tax benefit away from you so basically
what they're doing is
every city out there that's ever tried
to attract a manufacturer like Toyota in
Tennessee was given tremendous tax
benefits to build your factory here and
create jobs Mercedes in Alabama and and
and and Disney Once Upon a Time was
given a tax benefit and says come make
Jobs Here Come build you they were
almost their own country that's exactly
right that's the difference and that's
not common with anybody because they
have their own guidelines yeah because
it's very common in the Native American
communities it's huge here in Florida so
there is some uh but Native Americans it
has a reason for it because it's a way
of a reparation the negotiation they had
versus Disney is hey that's what was
similar to what Ron L Ron Hubbard
negotiated Scientology to be a religion
it's the same way Disney negotiated for
their land to be their own countries
making a case to start the religion of
Disney and they already they already
have one so my last Point here to wrap
it up so people can see it but when
Toyota comes to Tennessee it's an
established area when Toyota came to
Tennessee it was an established town
when Mercedes came to Alabama it was an
established location when Disney was
first given this it was a swamp where
they had a plan to build the city and
all the stuff that went with it so now
all those years later DeSantis is saying
hey you know what we're not going to do
this anymore you're not going to be your
own country your own thing we're going
to manage this area the same way we
manage everything else in the State of
Florida but let me ask you because you
bring up a great Point what was the
impetus for him doing this wasn't it
because Disney
and Bob chapac took the lead on these
culture wars that I was speaking about
and this is sort of punishment to say
you know keep talking [__] Disney and
we're gonna see what we're gonna do with
your tax benefits well I would summarize
it I would say you're I believe you're
on the right track with that and I think
it goes like this hey Disney you know
what thanks for nothing thanks for
nothing and you know for 20 years we've
been talking about your special
privilege District here and talking
about changing it guess what dude that
change happens today
so was it a little retaliatory yes but
this has been coming through a long time
this is how I see it I totally get what
you're saying I'm about uh debate
discourse let's talk let's uh hash it
out and then give the freedom
uh uh to do what you want to do and you
know let the market decide whether they
want to buy the product or not okay
however here's a question uh say you
have a new employee that works for you
and go five years from now you're
married with two kids okay
and this new ply of yours is working for
you you're helping them your Mentor he
comes to your house okay
first time you let them in your house
your wife makes him a meal and let's
just say your wife is very attractive
and he says oh wow Mary you look great
wow Adam you've got a beautiful wife
good for you okay he's being friendly no
problem all right
next time he comes back he says it again
now let's just say she's wearing a dress
and she says oh my God look at that body
of yours you look beautiful no problem
you're like okay little little too much
next time she comes she says I can't
believe how beautiful your lips are you
know and you're like
okay easy buddy there's a little bit
you're going okay so so Watch What
Happens Next Watch What Happens I like
the direction you're going but I'm going
to tell you exactly where I'm going with
this so the next time at this point
you're kind of like this is this is a
first of all I'm letting you my house
yeah then the next time he kisses your
wife on the cheek but a little too close
Okay like a calmly in the hug of the
hand is slightly lower okay
and at this point you're sitting there
saying all right bro we gotta have a
conversation okay so then your kids are
with them and he's playing with your
kids and he's getting a little bit too
much out of control the following time
his comments are getting worse and worse
and worse at what point do you say get
the hell out of my house what the hell
are you doing what is the matter with
you you've crossed the line there is no
more respect here's what Disney's done
over the years Disney was a place where
families went to to have fun no politics
no nothing we went to have fun
gradually they went from saying hey Adam
your kids are beautiful kids thank you
hey kids you don't have to listen to
your mom and dad what they have to say
you're a kid you may be more creative
than them like ah I'm not going hey kids
how are you you may be gay lesbian or
bisexual listen you've officially
crossed the line Disney and here's what
we have to do you're being put into
timeout this is a form of a punishment
for crossing the line and making it from
a place of entertainment to the kids to
wanting to indoctrinate and groom my
kids no you're arrested Disney here you
go so I'm fully supportive of what he
did I don't know how long this is going
to be staying there this needs to be a
precedent for any other Parks or places
that are being built for kids to realize
don't mess with other people's kids the
moment you do that you've officially
pissed off moms and dads and now you
have a bunch of enemies that are not
supposed part of what you're doing so I
like what he did I think he's showing
his power moves and quite frankly his
next job is going to go from being one
state which he raised 211 million
dollars for his job as a governor which
by the way we didn't say this last time
it was a record no one's ever raised
that kind of money before for governor
including uh uh obviously L.A California
what's a bigger number one Meg Whitman
was running but it's a record for what
he did he's gonna go next what are the
next things he has to tackle okay what
are the next things he has to tackle
yesterday I was watching the santis
a couple interviews I want to say he was
on I don't know what show he was he may
have been on Tucker and if you go on his
interview yesterday with Tucker don't
play it I just want you to show his face
and let me make one uh uh just a thought
on what I see happening here with the
santis okay if you go to that zoom in on
his face he's happy no no no no zoom in
on his face forget about the picture
they used or not okay do you know what I
noticed when I see that picture here's
what I notice
I see a man who wants to take every
single shot Trump's gonna take at him
away from him he does not look like a
meatball he looks like he's lost 20
pounds he looks good he looks like he's
got a full-time trainer he looks like
he's eating vegetables he looks like his
diet has changed he's gone off of starch
he looks like he may even be on some
kind of supplements amino acids some
kind of fat burner he's looking very
very good when that day comes when he
hits the stage he wants every single
thing to be gone let me make my
prediction the moment if president Trump
makes a comment about meatball he's
gonna say well let me just give you some
facts here because I know president
Trump you're about the truth yeah here's
some facts based on your doctors this is
your height this is your weight oh wow
my doctor gave me my height my weight my
body fat here's where I'm at I'm taking
care of my health wow I think it's
important I think he's strategic quickly
planning to show everybody how healthy
he freaking is and it's gonna go viral
oh my God I'm telling look at his face
look what he looks like pineapples and
he looks amazing he looks younger than
three years ago yeah he looks really
good and one of his hits is gonna be
this and uh Mr President my tan is
better than yours you orange I don't
know about that yeah I mean he's orange
I know he's looking really he looks good
but the point is he's looking really
really good if he's you know Camp I know
their Camp follows the content here he's
a shout out to him for taking care of
him you see what and you see what's
happening like the campaign is it's it's
rolling out for itself he's such a
likable guy his his military his seal
his you know you know his wife thank God
she's okay everything the family
everything's coming together he's
showing everybody uh Pat don't mess with
the kids leave the kids alone he showed
everybody that Florida kicks ass with
covet and like this is the place to be
and he's not gonna lock you down I'm
telling you right now bro he's gonna be
a hard guy to be do you think he
actually is likable or he's trying to
become more likable because here's
here's where I'm going with this and
this granted this is a New York Times
article and they basically gave a book
review they're basically saying this is
someone with no Charisma or no humor
which is I would tend to agree I've
never heard Ron DeSantis make a funny
joke I've never been like that's the
kind of guy I want to get a beer with
but I'll tell you what uh I'm okay with
a serious president I'm okay with
someone with credibility I'm okay with
someone who's non-nonsense I'm okay with
that so my only question is
how much is charisma because of The
Seven Elements of what makes a present
wasn't like the deciding factor their
Charisma what was that whole that
friendly bet that you had with uh with
our buddy the uh
is one of them so there's no denying
that Trump has Charisma Charisma for
days it's just is he as serious as a
candidate as
Ron DeSantis is is potentially going to
be but I absolutely think Pat's analysis
is spot on he's trying to take every
single piece of ammunition away oh maybe
20 pounds overweight yeah let me lose 20
pounds look my best meanwhile Trump's
not getting anything let me tell you
the Memoir is the reason why he's going
you know it's like oh I know for a fact
he's gonna run all this other the reason
why I'm now certain this guy is going to
announce that he's running is because
he's lost weight I'm telling you because
he understands Optics whoever's on the
inside with his consultant they're
saying look at John F Kennedy on the
camera how great he looked I there's
some stuff with the forehead looks good
you know there's some things in Florida
we are in a very young so what I'm
saying like you know what you do you
know he's looking really good so go
ahead Tom you're gonna say something no
I'm looking forward to the campaign and
by my the primary candidates are coming
out it's starting to happen because I
think America is ready for the election
it's going to be bloody rolling into it
because right now we don't have a
president we have elder abuse you know
we've got I think some things coming
that I think are going to be good and I
think this is a sign of one of the many
people that are going to be running and
let's face it DeSantis is running that
are getting revved up for their whether
it's your five minutes in the Spotlight
Nikki Haley because you want to position
yourself for a position
which is I think what's happening there
or you want to make your point on
National stage Marianne Williamson or
you really want to be part of it and you
want to run
um I I don't I think you hit the nail in
the head with the Elder Bruce Gavin
Newsom I think there is such a yearning
in our country for if you're 75 plus
thank you for your your service thank
you for serving the country it's time
for the millennial and gen xers to
really Step Up Now what and that is the
sentences you mean you're you're not I'm
having I I'm starting to like biting
more like did you see what he said
yesterday I'm just saying
McConnell thank you for your service
left and right peace but I don't know I
don't know if we're ready for somebody
that serious because I love like Biden
yesterday he was speaking for the Black
History Month he says tell you about the
divine nine and he was like I may be a
white boy but I'm not stupid and got a
standing ovation like I'm I'm gonna miss
that just goofy old he's like a comedy
guy he can always go back
yes the highlight videos highlight of
look uh every week how many how many
tripping on the stairs videos oh my God
see the one with the balloon hits them
no no did you see the one in Ukraine
where actually somebody was on the back
stairs her first one fell and took out
three other people yeah it was hilarious
it's like yeah so now we have fail
videos
did you see what he said this is this is
yesterday pack he was speaking in DC
about Black History Month about the
divine nine let's look at watches I I
may be a white boy but I'm not stupid
look at the girl on the right the the
sign language the best he goes she was
throwing up gang she looks like it
actually I was I was offended by that I
think in the middle of Black History
Month there's so much to look back on in
America let me
um I think when you're pandering for the
crowd like what I think what is that I
think that's wait what is what is that
is that true yesterday yeah is this
picture real
[Laughter]
it's real or no
wait you're serious this is real no
when is this what happens
that is hilarious by the way someone's
gonna go say where's Kamala yeah oh my
God Heaven Ain't Easy so so so what is
this you put up random Township
leadership Florida yeah this is the book
but but here's what I want to do what
you just did transitions into a story I
want to read to you this is what happens
when you keep calling whites racist it
turns on you and then you have to make
your argument so watch this very
interesting
most hated white students sues
historically black college for two
million dollars over racial
discrimination okay over racial it's not
something how could you say this is
racist no no it's just using your own
you know play it's a play out of your
playbook that you've been using uh a
white student Michael Newman who
attended Howard University's law school
from the fall semester of 2020 to
September of 2022 is using the
institution for racial discrimination
claiming that the school created a
hostile education environment Newman is
seeking two million dollars of monetary
damages for pain suffering emotional
anguish and damage to his reputation
Newman suffered depression anxiety and
Suicidal Thoughts as a result of public
ostracism uh vilification and
humiliation and the lawsuit claims that
the student at the schools responded
with references to his race gender
sexual preference age and personal
preference personal appearance after
learning of a tweet from new Newman's
private Twitter account that included a
picture of a slave with a caption but we
don't know what he did before the
picture was taken Newman's lawyers will
try to prove this School broke its
contract with Newman a student who
attended on a scholarship after a series
of incidents and accusations led to
multiple review panels and hearings that
resulted in his expulsion you know you
know what happens when you scream racism
racism racism racism racism constantly
you water it down for when somebody
really is being victimized yeah and then
all of a sudden you have a story like
this and then you have to argue well no
racism doesn't exist in this college no
racism doesn't exist in the NBA even
though 70 African Americans no racism
doesn't exist in XYZ then arguments get
lost for example you know that one meme
that's gone viral and a bunch by the way
this meme was posted on PVD podcast and
Instagram immediately immediately
corrected it did you see this meme that
some of these memes they put on pbd
podcasts
funny uh uh well I I I I I gotta tell
you the guys that manage bbdp I manage
Instagram pbd but PVD podcast managed by
uh our guy who's a beast uh he posted
something go up to see if it's all the
way at the top that's the one that's
hidden it's the one that's hidden with
warning go lower I'll warning that one
right there click on that one okay so
watch this uh see why look what this
meme says what it's okay with the fact
Checkers zoom in on the fact check oh
we'll we'll go to the fact Checkers
afterwards okay first let's read what
this meme is
can we see the meme it has to allow you
to see the meme it says see post on the
bottom look what this says I wonder why
there are no women transitioning to men
and trying to compete in men's sports
why is that so but they they just read
it one more time I wonder why there are
no women transitioning to men and trying
to compete in men's sports it's a lot
harder to do it's a lot harder to do of
course so Instagram fact checks it I go
back on it to read this fact check uh uh
go back to you how to write the question
why yeah and zoom in
the same false information was reviewed
by another fact Checker there are there
are there may be small differences it
says fact check it's not true
that no athletes assign female at Birth
transition then try to compete in men's
sports Elite stories okay wow tell me
how many stories of women became men
that try to compete in swimming in
wrestling in uh in Olympics in sprinting
tell me in in what in what that we read
about that you've actually read about
I'm sure it's happened I'm sure it's
happened but tell me when you've seen it
when it became a big story and day one
at the highest level that we had to see
where other men are like no no it's not
fair that you're transitioning when see
this this is the great thing about
debate and patience because what happens
with bad ideas if you're patient
just give it time eventually bad ideas
are going to be exposed on their own
without you even making an effort you
know when your kids sometimes say daddy
I'm I haven't gone through it yet but
I'm about to go through it my kids are
right now what they're they're 19 months
old you know six years old nine years
old 11 years old you know what phase I'm
in right now with my kids every parent
with their kids goes through three
phases phase number one they idolize you
okay phase number two they demonize you
yeah phase number three they humanize
you guess what phase I'm in with my kids
right now they idolize me love it's a
good phase they love me I don't do
anything wrong today right give it a
couple years give it a couple years
where they're gonna say what that you
have no clue what you're talking about
all you care about is capitalism do you
know the roots of capitalism do you know
what Thomas Jefferson and Benjamin
Franklin and Ben Russian George
Washington and April do you know what
they did how could you that how could
you and I'm gonna say honey son
uh Tico Dylan Santa bro whatever shown
you are I'm gonna be like okay bro
I'm patient okay in about 10 years
you're gonna realize how shitty of an
idea you're buying into right now I'm
patient don't worry the same thing that
a parent has to go through with their
kids is the same thing that the populace
has to go through in the media a certain
institution a political party a certain
sect decides to impose a dumb idea that
makes no sense and has zero common sense
and all you have to do is oh my God how
long is it going to take till you
realize how dumb of an idea this is I'm
patient I'm going to be right here
anyways it looks like you're trying to
show something so whatever you're trying
to do you made us read books Dad yeah
jerk I hate you I love it any thoughts
on this because before we go on you guys
are doing something with Rob Rob will
you guys was Adam sending you a story or
no okay I
it would this be a natural progression
to to talk about a transition to talk
about that Dilbert situation I was just
looking at things okay what was the
natural to what Bill Dilbert's situation
that's also has to do with racism did
you read that story go forward which one
is that that's his story about what
happened with the creator of Dilbert I
mean since we're on the topic of This
Racist cartoonist says a rebuke of
Dilbert Creator Scott Adams is long
overdue so here's the story so and by
the way Elon Musk laid into the late uh
weighed in on this so Elon Musk recently
took to Twitter to suggest that the U.S
media is now racist against white people
and Asian people as he seemingly
defended the Dilbert comic strip Creator
Scott Adams who made racist comments
that led to several newspapers dropping
his cartoon muskrut for a very long time
the U.S media was racist against
non-white people now they're racist
against whites and Asians so same thing
happened with Elite colleges and high
schools in America maybe they can try
not being racist so here's what happens
Adam's comments came after erasmus's
poll revealed that 53 of black Americans
agreed with the statement it's okay to
be white
weird number in response
Adams posted an online video which he
said if nearly half of all blacks are
not okay with white people that's a hate
group
I don't want to have anything to do with
them and I would say based on the
current way things are going the best
advice I would give to white people is
get the hell away from black people
because there's no fixing this
Jesus Christ
that's a little that's a little too too
crazy about it there is a misconception
out there though that like
if you're a certain rate you can't be
racist towards white people and I'm
sorry bro if you hate a race and you're
always like I hate why people are the
you know you cracker dude that's that's
a racial that's a racial story you're
being racist either it's either be okay
with it yeah and have a thicker skin or
stop doing it on both sides exactly very
simple so guess guess what's believe it
or not
you know uh I'll tell you what oh go
ahead yeah I mean you have to understand
that either position you make and you
take you're going to contradict yourself
of course you're gonna end up being a
hypocrite and the American people are
gonna sit there and say yeah you're full
of [__] I'm not buying that's what's
gonna happen just you just have to be
patient with it anyways did you want to
say more things
um
it is sad or unfortunate to see this
number you know 53 of black people's in
this poll
uh
agreed that it's okay to be white sort
of a shocking number but I think his
response and his approach is actually
pretty disgusting so he says his answer
is I don't have anything to do with them
and I would say based on the current
things they're going the best advice is
to give white people to stay the hell
away from black people that's a racist
piece of [__] if you ask me maybe he
actually is racist so for me as I hear
that because I'm more of a natural
synergist I would want to say hey
you know I would say something if this
is my cartoon Dilbert I would say you
know the old uh Rodney King thing why
can't we all get along let's work on
this let's work on this together you
know I get that you've been wronged and
there's things that we need to address
but his approach is is the exact
opposite of way I would go not deal with
black people what does that even mean
yeah so to me that is uh
counterintuitive to what you're doing
but you do need a strong
African-American leader like Elon Musk
to step up in a moment like this yeah
good call he is from South Africa I
think the poll speaks for itself and
it's really unfortunate
um I you know to have any group of
people have that kind of a position and
the way he commentated because he moved
from just talking about a poll into
commentated and the way he commentated
was pretty bad however we've had a
recent guest and we've also seen the
lawsuit brought by Asian Americans
against Yale on discriminatory practices
on admissions so we are seeing uh
precedents out there where people are
saying hey when the pendulum swings the
other way you have to understand it you
you are you are making a bias against
somebody and a bias against anybody is
not good so anyway yeah you know my kids
uh Dylan asked me a question he said say
daddy so so when people ask me in school
what am I what do I say
I said what do you mean
it says do I say I'm half white I'm nine
percent Italian I'm half a Syrian I'm
half Armenian how do I explain listen
you got to be proud of all of it it's
what you are okay you are half American
you have a little bit of Italian and
you're according to ancestry I don't
know anyone in my family that's hooked
up with neither one I said who but yeah
there's some Italian in there and then
you got Armenian and Assyrian and you
got to be proud of it all and that's how
God created you and we get along with
everybody okay and when they have a
Christmas when we have a birthday party
here's Tico Tico wanted 55 of his
classmates to come to his freaking
birthday party 55 I mean there's like
three fifth grades he says I want
everybody to come what are you talking
about
five and by the way you know what
happened in 11 years old parents if
you're listening to this this is not
cool
I am not a babysitter here's what they
do when kids turn 11 parents came
dropped off their kids they left three
hours came back three hours to pick him
up no you know what I'm gonna next time
I'm gonna give him a bill of freaking of
course five thousand dollars
babysitting business
the point is when the kids friends came
dude it's like you got the United
Nations was in the backyard it was
awesome but uh it is what it is I want
to go to the story here
I want to go to the store here do you
have the uh tweet about uh El Salvador
and what they're doing there to uh their
MS-13 gangs and what happens to uh their
stats do you have that video if if you
don't I think I sent it to you on
Twitter it's funny when I posted this I
I very interesting what Twitter did all
of a sudden I don't even know if
twitters or Elon is even aware of this
or not I'll just send it to you right
now it's got a few million views online
I think it's important for you to see
this here's the link it's a Twitter clip
to show I just send it to you just go to
my own uh uh go to my Twitter yeah and
then go to Media go to Media to the
right and let's see how low to let you
go keep going keep going keep going okay
that one right there now watch this yeah
zoom out a little bit okay uh uh play
this clip from the beginning it's a one
minute clip turn on the audio place
there you go just play this clip and
listen to this folks and tell me if you
think this is a good idea or a bad idea
watch this
it looks like a sea of skin and tattoos
these images released by El Salvador's
government shows the transfer of about 2
000 inmates stripped to their shorts and
with their heads shaved to what's been
dubbed to the country's new Mega prison
it just opened it's believed to be the
largest prison in the Americas with a
capacity for 40 000 people and it's the
latest step in a controversial Crackdown
on crime that's caused the country's
prison population the soar watch the
stats though rights organizations have
reported that innocent people have been
caught up in the law enforcement
campaign
that includes dozens notice all their
faces are covered so these guys don't
remember
last year the country's president asked
Congress for emergency powers to
temporarily suspend some constitutional
rights after a massive spike in murders
attributed to gang crime includes that
arrests can be made without a warrant
and detainees no longer have a right to
a lawyer private Communications of all
citizens can also be accessed by the
government since then about 64 000
suspects have been arrested the murder
reports fell about 57 percent did you
hear that yeah okay go back go back 10
seconds to hear that stat again it's
important for the audience to hear that
go right there right there and play it
listen to the staff the government since
then about 64 000 suspects have been
arrested the murder reports fell about
57 percent wow
okay so pause it commentary on it is
wild uh this Reuters for whatever reason
flagged this for me and said warning
they put a warning on this tweet because
it might have sensitive content I'm like
this is not even my tweet I'm retweeting
a Reuters tweet what and Reuters didn't
get the warning I got the warning I'll
send it to you Rob if you want to put it
up there so is this a good idea or is
this a bad idea with what El Salvador is
doing 64 000 people arrested crime is
down 57 percent I think it's great I
think it's great um I I think people
need to go back and take a look at what
really happened in California when
Kamala Harris was attorney general the
three strikes law uh wacken Hut uh
building more prisons here which is
prisons for profit and you see what
happened in California they were trying
to drop the uh the crime rate too and so
I I think what they're trying to do they
have this they have this terrible crime
problem and they're like all right let's
just round up all the MS-13 gang members
and let's watch the statistics and
unless they're monkeying with the
numbers
um
you've got a 57 dropped murders okay
well guess what's happening they're
getting the outcome they wanted and you
could debate whether you like the way
they're doing it but this is the outcome
they wanted less murders in their
community
was that drastic measure times calls for
drastic measures if the yo and the stats
don't lie 50 murder rate down I'm sorry
bro if you look like that and you're
doing some gangster [__] but bye I have
no remorse zero yeah my what what is
even the pushback here can you go
to the tweet and let's read some of the
comments I think that's the best thing
to do just go to the tweet and let's
read some of the comments uh yeah go to
the Tweet so zoom in a little bit so we
can so tough on Chrome is good but not
by suspending their constitution so
click on it to read the replies that's
Jake shields uh I agree okay I agree but
at the same time if you legitimately
commit violent crimes you forfeit your
rights the only area of concern is the
judicial system being corrupt innocent
people being convicted agreed agree okay
let's read then how many innocent people
die because certain individuals weren't
in police custody go to the next one I
was in El Salvador before they were uh
rounded up and your life was in danger
every second you left your house this is
good makes me happy citizens that want
to just make a living focus on being
harder on crime focus on punishing
criminals focusing on squeezing as many
criminals in one place as possible can
only lead to bad outcomes
um instead Focus needs to be shifted
from punishing people to rehabilitating
criminal here we go into functioning
citizens okay how do you do that is the
question everyone's asking right I've
only
I've known family members that we hope
could be rehabilitated the unfortunate
reality is that the probability of
success is quite low the cartel was
terrorizing your town murdered your
family members I have a feeling you
would say something different
during the time which resembles 1930s
previous decade marked by conflict and
eroding world order to covet declining
institutional trust as multiple layers
and across the world Spectrum I feel
this doesn't end here my mother is a in
law is El Salvadorian she grew up there
and just went on vacation there and came
back last week she said she felt so much
safer this time than any time she can
remember they could stay out and go to
restaurants at night she thanked God for
it wow I mean these this is this is the
great thing about a platform like this
because you're seeing different sides
and arguments people are making go ahead
well I mean we say this all the time
about the number one thing a mother is
concerned is her kids and are her kids
what's the s word safe so if you're
you're just trying to we talk about if
you could go live anywhere and start a
country where would you go the number
one thing is are you safe and it just
would seem to be with all these gang
members running around El Salvador just
people don't feel safe and you know
numbers don't lie murder has gone down
53 yeah since they've started rounding
up the MS-13 gang members uh the numbers
speak for themselves I think it's a
great thing you know I I I I I get why
there is some pause for a concern you
know are you eliminating the
Constitution whatever that was yeah
whatever they're doing wasn't working
yeah it was a murder it was a murderous
country yeah so uh kudos for taking some
action and did you you guys saw what I
saw every single one of those guys they
look identical
same shaved heads uh dude those guys
don't need to be on public and that's
that's MS-13 those guys are they're not
just regular gang members or those guys
are ruthless bro they're nuts but look
at that all the same guy very easy to
identify you if you have tattoos on your
head body by the way there's a speech
that the president of El Salvador gave
okay
um is it still uh is the country that
has been the Bitcoin country yes is that
the same guy yes oh about time they
clean this up it's the same guy that's
been he's doing a hero of the crypto
he's doing it okay great it's making
sense by the way he gave a speech it's
on my Instagram account yeah it's two
minutes long it's in it's in Spanish but
there's a what do you call it captions
there
you have to read the speech he gives it
gives me it's it's a long time ago it's
like probably three weeks ago I posted
this it gives me the chills if you can
keep going down you'll find it it gives
me the chills on the message right there
right there he gives this message we
don't have to play it right now but you
know uh uh the the way he talks he says
we know we're a small country we know
our limits but we're not going to stay
small okay we're not here to just be
another country in El Salvador you guys
think big you guys have great things we
respect you a lot we respect what you've
done but we want to be there as well the
guy speaks like a guy you want speaking
on behalf of your country that's not
apologizing he's saying our crime is
this he's saying all this up but we're
gonna get better and we're going to be a
great country versus apologizing
constantly for being white apologizing
for believing in capitalism apologizing
for being a country that's whooped on
everybody being ashamed of who you are
there's a lot of Pride to the way this
man speaks yeah leaders who have pride
in their nationality in their country in
their people understanding to stay
humble stay you know a
reasonable individual he sounds like
someone like that he doesn't raise his
voice he speaks very calmly if you've
not heard the speech before highly
recommend watching this speech it's
powerful anyways I got a couple other
stories I want to talk about here before
we wrap up and by the way some of you
guys are watching this you're commenting
your messaging saying hey you know I
kind of like what you got on let me show
you the back of this which is sick check
this out
okay dude that is so badass
uh anyways we're having a whole new
military gear that's coming out because
being a a guy that I have a lot of
respect for our veterans thank you for
your service thank you and being the
Airman of the year in the entire Air
Force that's one of these coming out
these what the whole series is about to
be launched where green value team and
future looks bright house but this is
just a teaser the shirt quality is
amazing it's one of my favorite quality
shirts to wear if you would like to
sport one of these you're a veteran or
you love America or you love our
military or your support our military uh
I suggest you go get this validation
shirt on the front of it says businesses
War it's just the reality a business
Works get this new one this is New Gear
being dropped for the first time here
today uh put the link below Rob for
people to be able to get it and I think
there's people that want to
uh participate in merch that we have if
you do want to be the first to find out
about the drop that we're having text
award merch to
310-340-1132 one more time merch merch
Texas two three one zero three four zero
one one three two if you text that
you're gonna get the direct link back of
this shirt to place the order uh uh
since we have the sizes right now before
the size of sellout anyways okay last
thing I want to talk about with the
story we just went into military and I
want to wrap it up with a couple stories
on Military so you know how we're
sitting then we're watching how much us
keeps giving to Ukraine keeps given to
Ukraine and yelling just went there this
week and she announced that they're
given an additional 1.2 but 1.2 billion
ten but promising ten right here's 1.2
but promising ten
uh uh uh uh but promising 10 uh and you
know so people like oh my God how much
more money I think the total right now
is 114 billion dollars give or take okay
you realize a couple things you know
what's the fastest way to stop this war
if you're so worried about 300 000
people that have died with the number
that you give us 200 000 on the Russia's
and a hundred thousand on Ukraine's and
you know what's the fastest way to
finish the war do you know what's the
fastest way to finish the war stop
giving money yeah do you realize that if
you really don't want war
stop giving money and set up the meeting
how come you haven't done that it's as
if America wants this war to continue so
when a Tulsi gabbard or some of these
guys get up and they talk about the
military
industrial complex you keep funding this
there's a reason why millions of people
resonate with what Tulsi gabbard and
others have to say maybe you do want to
war maybe this is a business model maybe
there is a benefit of us doing this to
continue this model that we're going
with all these wars because if America
truly wants no war right now you can
stop the money you can stop sending
weapons and if you do that Ukraine has
no choice to say let's talk let's figure
something out right now watch this
if you can pull up one of the things
that we've been sending to uh uh to uh
uh Ukraine is these Javelin missile
launchers okay a couple stats I want you
to see with this year if you can go back
to the first one go all the way to the
first one go one more there's one other
picture I sent you uh uh which is the
budget that we have okay zoom in on this
picture here take a look at this this is
our budget in 2021 versus other
military's budget that we have us 801 in
2021 look at China look at India you
could look at UK look at everyone else
we have a massive military budget that
we have a big chunk of this is financing
the 800 military bases that we have okay
trying to solve other people's problems
but the one thing we've given to to to
Ukraine a lot is 8 500 javelins to
Ukraine that's what US has committed if
you want to Google what a javelin is and
what it looks like military Ukraine so
people can see it 8 500 of them that's
been given to Ukraine there's a reason
why Ukraine is doing so well against
Russia because we this is not a war with
Ukraine against Russia this is a war of
U.S versus Russia okay period it's
public it's not even something we're
hiding we've given 8 500 of those to
Ukraine so what's the big deal
you know somebody may say what's that
what's the big deal about these javelins
were given to them Raytheon and Lockheed
Martin have both said that what's been
pledged from U.S in existing stock they
cannot do double the production and give
America back what they have till 2026
meaning everything we pretty much have
on stock of javelins we've pretty much
given to who to Ukraine okay these are
the numbers that we've given to them
just to support what they got going on
so now as you get closer with this
article that Wall Street Journal has
they show this data Tom you're gonna
love this year if you can show this on
the screen so our audience can see this
these are the numbers of contractors U.S
had in 1980 that we did business with
okay when I say contractors defense
company contractors okay that this is
where we got our weapons from so if you
look at this Vinnie 1981 there was 51
companies we did business with
every year or so one or two got bought
out we went from 51 to how many down to
five oh wow Lockheed Martin Boeing
Raytheon Northrop Grumman and General
Dynamics okay so one could look at this
and say well what's uh the big deal with
this show the next data if you go to
this one go two more go one more okay
from 1990 the number of contractors we
had tactical missile suppliers we had 13
that we bought from we only have three
today fixed Wing aircraft suppliers we
had eight we got three today satellite
suppliers we had eight we got four today
Builders of surface ships we had eight
we have two today okay
these guys that keep buying up these
companies this is essentially being a
similar model to Banks how many banks do
we have in 1980s a ton of them how many
banks do we have today it's really only
five companies or cell phone companies
cell phone companies
everything is going to this everything I
remember being on a call with FTC when
one of the bigger Insurance technology
companies that's a behemoth if you're on
the insurance don't say the name if
you're in the insurance industry you
know who I'm talking about they were
about to buy up another competitor whom
we were doing business with both of them
and they said hey we would like to know
XYZ they're asking because they were
pretty much having a monopoly some of
these guys have so much control right
now which the problem becomes the
following is America
you know how you raise money and all of
a sudden you buy 50 different companies
one by one by one by one by one you keep
buying other companies because you have
the money and then all of a sudden what
happens to you you wake up one day
you're like dude we got 400 companies
that we bought the last five years
we have no clue how to manage these
companies one by one they're going
bankrupt what the hell are we gonna do
you've stretched yourself so thin you
now have four or 500 military bases to
manage how do you do that the problem
today with America is if we keep giving
all these weapons to other people our
own supply is getting weaker and
Northrop and Raytheon are saying we
can't replace this for you till 2026.
that's three years our own military is
getting weaker the more we try to
support everyone God forbid if the enemy
realizes that military and U.S
is experiencing this what does that tell
you that's an opportunity for what
attack to attack of course to realize
hey they're not as strong as we once
thought of course that's a real threat
and to say that we're getting this close
to a potential War
this is the closest we've been since you
know what do you want to call the Cuban
Missile Crisis I would say that's the
closest we've been where we could be a
part of this and we keep poking the
Bears so then the story leads to this
and then Tom I want to get your thoughts
on this first and then I'm going to come
to you next okay as our AI expert so
story comes out Putin will die in office
or with bullets in his back as despots
Futures predicted okay so this is a
story on page 13 War expert Nate Sibley
believes that Vladimir Putin will die
while serving as President of Russia and
that he could be assassinated simply
states that Putin's watched carefully as
other Soviet Union leaders try to
extricate themselves from authoritarian
regimes as they failed and that whatever
his future holds it is increasingly
unlikely to be a happy ending either of
old age or bulletin is back Putin has
previously survived several
assassination attempts with Oliver Stone
stating in 2012 interview that he had
heard of five attempts Putin himself
responded I do my job and the security
officers do theirs and they're still
performing quite successfully Putin's
Health has been a subject of much
speculation over the years with claims
that he has Parkinson's and travels with
a thyroid cancer doctor however he has
stated in the past that he has no plans
to retire and he has changed the
Constitution to allow him to rule
indefinitely make in modern day in
Russia a true autocracy so
with all this stuff going on in the
world and the uncertainties that we have
I I just think America may want to kind
of step back and take an inventory are
we as strong as we act like we are or we
have stretched ourselves so thin around
the world that this may have given an
opening for somebody to say you know
what if there's ever been a time to
attack maybe this is the time obviously
nobody wants to see War this next one
won't be pretty the goal is to prevent
this war Tom what are your thoughts on
this well first of all every Russian
leader dies in office because as much as
they say oh we have elections here yeah
right your guys service until he doesn't
right that's the way that is and to say
well he'll either die in office which is
a certainty or he'll die in office with
assistance you know because he's going
to get shot I I don't think there's
really a story there but what you're
talking about is where is the United
States really on the world stage and I
agree with you if you just to unload the
cupboard and give all this stuff to the
Ukraine the first thing I worry about is
you know Ukraine is kind of depleted on
their own military Pat you know how do
we feel when Russians capture a
Ukrainian unit and they get a hold a
couple of these now they got our stuff
and they can take it apart and figure it
out and you know copy it that's always
been part of war is capture the other
guy's crap and then reverse engineer it
or find out the secrets that are inside
as weapons
and I I think that the U.S on a world
stage right now you know is is a little
bit depleted now this is a defense
contractor saying it's going to take me
five years to I mean two years to
rebuild all those missiles and can I uh
can I send you an invoice today
it's also people sit there and go uh Hey
buy some Raytheon today well by the way
I'm sure those guys are loving what's
going on I'm sure they're saying send
more stuff to you pull that more stuff
to Ukraine because I got to replace it
for you and there's only five of us yeah
we're competing against the defense
contractors Believe It or Not Lobby for
a thing called war games where you see
the war games going on yeah they do that
in South Korea yeah they they Lobby for
the use of it
um and now obviously they don't use
nukes in war games but they use up a lot
of stuff they do simulations they do a
lot of things and then you need
replacement parts you need all the stuff
and it's another invoice to the defense
contractors but to your core Point yeah
I do think we're getting slightly
weakened on an international stage in
terms of actual
um Readiness of having the tools that we
need to fight and then we're also I
think getting weak because you know
we could do five podcasts in a row on
the flip-flops on Ukraine we're just
gonna let it's not our business it's
from it's not our business dude here's
billions of dollars worth of stuff to
fight remember where this started uh
We're not gonna get involved in a proxy
war and be shipping our stuff over there
uh okay give them some tanks remember
this yeah it's been a slippery slope and
so we I don't think our position looks
very strong we change every three weeks
and I I think we're weaker on a world
stage I think that the best what's the
uh saying in football what are Ravens
wanted offense is defense yeah the best
offense is a great deal yeah that's what
Ronald Reagan said if we have a great
military defense guess what no one is
doing anything now you know how you know
you create fun account like you're like
hey you know I have a savings your
investment you're this and you create a
what you create a sports account or
whatever you want to call it right yeah
you know what the funny Council bludgeon
account is to me here's the weapons that
we can give to others for support but we
will never touch what we need to be
protected so this is when we need to be
protected guess what yeah the javelin
we're hitting shortage we can only give
you 700 we can't give you the whole 8
600. yeah those are the things as long
as we're playing within those parameters
then we can support those that have
generally been a good Ally to us I'll
just say this uh I think we have every
right to question the amount of money
that is going to Ukraine okay what I
think is unquestionable is standing up
to authoritarian regimes who are
invading Sovereign Nations I mean if you
look at this this this article right
Ukraine is the West War now it's not
just the US it is the entire you know
Western World Western Civilization the
EU NATO okay but here it is the Western
alliances geopolitical adversaries are
calculating whether the U.S and its
allies have the stamp stamina and the
cohesion to defend here it is the
rules-based international order that has
benefited the West for decades the
future of Taiwan of Taiwan and South
China Sea is closely linked to the West
record
in Ukraine so there's precedent there's
rules there's a rules-based
international order like we've said
before you can't just go invade a
country what precedent does that does
that establish so next thing you know he
invades Ukraine and then then it's what
he takes over Kiev he owns Ukraine now
and then it's Poland and then what
happens so at some point the only thing
that strong men
respond to is the word no you can't do
[__] like this Putin we have every right
to question how much money we're
spending totally right
but to stand you know there's hard power
and there's soft power right now we need
to be projecting both hard power is
actually fighting in Wars but soft power
is also standing for democracy no nobody
like for example what FDR did to get a
third term you know and what Putin's
doing to get a third term and what he
was doing to uh what was his name is
Vivaldi or uh uh navalny you know what
was his uh in Russia the competitor of
election of all new where the airport
flight he was insane we're not
supportive of that at all whatsoever no
one is saying that all I'm saying is you
can't control what your enemy does you
try to America has tried for many many
years and some of them they've been able
to control this is not an enemy you can
control we have to Pivot on our own
knowing
discretionary that we can afford after
all our expenses are covered fine but
our expenses are not covered our defense
is not covered and we're trying to solve
everyone's problems yeah and we're
spending way too much money with this
anyways
um gang enjoy today's podcast yes I
believe well I'm not even going to tell
you what's going to happen next couple
weeks we got a lot of
exciting things that's going to be
announced uh this last week I had a
great conversation with uh Andrew Tate's
lawyer Tina which by the way the
coincidence we went to the same high
school
high school she's
literally three years apart in high
school years we went to we knew some of
the same people that's right and she
happens to have been Jesse's attorney
Michael Jackson Chris Brown coach all
these other people we had a very good
conversation he's a beast she's
absolutely abused of a person a beast of
a lawyer uh and then I had a good
conversation with some of the people on
the inside working with Tate uh and it's
going to be interesting what happens the
next 30 60 90 days obviously some things
that was shared I can't disclose at all
but uh we're gonna see what the future
looks like here with that story there's
a lot of things that the the Romania's
government is trying to do we'll see
what will come out but all I can say is
the next few weeks we got some
interesting shows that we'll be
launching appreciate you guys for
joining us today Rob is there anything
we have going on this week before we
wrap up yes Thursday Roger Clemens 9 A.M
oh Roger Clemens is coming Tuesday
for all of you who love sports and you
love baseball that small community who
loves baseball the great Roger Clemens
will be here with us and by the way if
you don't love baseball I love baseball
so this is going to be more of an
interview for me if you want to watch it
come join us Thursday if not just know
what we're going to be talking about on
Thursday with Roger Clemens take care
everybody bye-bye bye-bye